it's a seventh game already this year  with 20 plus points he's got a couple of  30-point games  there's lonzo for three good  nice fine  and bridges  lamelo looking to answer for three  that's good  his second field goal in first three  pointer tonight quickly but to have the  concentration though the defender's  still there and he made it lonzo  so alonso ball now in double figures  he's got 11 points  [Applause]  ken lamello answer  you bet  all right here comes the second year man  richards turning 24 and starting an nba  game for the first time for billy  donovan's chicago bulls currently the  fifth best record in the eastern  conference there's lonzo where norm van  leer's old number oh zach levine demar  derozan javonte green